tout on retrouve à ottawa françois
philippe champagne le ministre de
l'innovation des sciences et de
l'industrie bonsoir monsieur champagne
bonsoir monsieur fillion vous allez bien
ça va bien cette décision était attendue
depuis quoi trois ans pourquoi cela a
pris autant de temps et quand on parle
d' enjeu de sécurité nationale vous
savez ces bonnes courses l'idée je pense
que les téléspectateurs vont comprendre
c'est être prendre la bonne décision on
a consulté les agences de renseignement
au canada on a consulté nos alliés le
processus qu'on a qu'on a fait c'est
qu'on plus alors c'est pour ça que
maintenant on est prêt à annoncer qu'on
va exclure huawei zte de
l'infrastructure 5g au canada mais les
américains avaient décidé depuis
longtemps les britanniques la
nouvelle-zélande l'australie les membres
du forez vos principaux partenaires dans
en question sur les questions de
sécurité avaient déjà fait leur choix
est-ce que la ferme gwangju la sphère
des 200 écoles de tout ralenti
voudraient quand on a des décisions
comme celle là qui sont tous importants
parce qu'on parle du réseau aujourd'hui
mais aussi pour les décider à venir
c'est une décision qui tient compte de
l'intérêt du canada qui tient compte de
notre sécurité nationale et qui tient
compte aussi comment on peut mieux
protéger une des infrastructures qui
seront les plus critiques pour les
générations à venir parce qu'on sait que
dans 5 g c'est l'internet des objets
c'est les voitures autonomes alors il y
aura beaucoup de trafic qui va passer
dans notre réseau alors l'idée c'est
d'assurer la résilience est ce que vous
voyez aujourd'hui non seulement c'est
que on indique notre intention mais on
va aussi proposer un cadre juridique qui
va nous permettre d'ajouter les
compagnies de corchia qui pourraient
poser un enjeu à la sécurité nationale
du canada de la décennie à venir et
quand on parle de sécurité nationale
c'est quoi on craint que la chine
espionne de canada mais sur la base des
recommandations vous savez c'est un
processus comme vous l'avez dit qui a
duré pendant quelques années on a
consulté les agences de renseignement
les agents de sécurité nos alliés et sur
la base des conclusions auxquelles les
agences sont arrivés sa forme est la
base de décisions pour prendre la
décision d'aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire
d'exclure ces deux compagnies lot de
notes réseau entreprendre et je peux
parler dans le détail des conclusions
qui ont été formulées mais ce que je
peux dire aux gens qui nous regardent ce
soir c'est qu'évidemment ce qui a été le
le point cardinal dans notre analyse
c'était vraiment d'assurer la sécurité
nationale mais pour le long terme à
monsieur fignon parce que vous comprenez
comme moi que cette infrastructure
doivent être avec nous pendant des
prochaines décennies les entreprises
telus 1 milliards d'équipements de web
elle de 500 millions à 1 milliard ces
entreprises doivent retirer les
équipements huawei de leurs réseaux pour
quoi oui bah on a donné un échéancier il
ya une échéance et qui dit qu'ils ne
pourront plus acheter certains des
équipements il y a aussi un échéancier
qui prévoit que les équipements qui aura
peut être installé dans le réseau 5g
devra aussi être enlevée même chose avec
le 4 juin on aura des discussions avec
évidemment pour que tout ça ça se passe
bien la raison qui on est ce que c'est
des compensations des dédommagements je
vais être clair avec tout le monde les
compagnies devront s'en tenir à la non
ce qu'on a fait aujourd'hui mais c'est
clair que le gouvernement fédéral
n'entend pas compenser mais la bonne
nouvelle je vous dirais monsieur fillion
c'est que la grande majorité du réseau
5g au canada n'inclut pas des produits
ou des services qui viennent soit de
huawei ou 2 était un alors ce soir ce
qu'on donne c'est une clarté aux marchés
à l'égard de la prévisibilité les gens
savent maintenant exactement où on s'en
va et travailleurs des pour les achats
qui devrait être fait par les compagnies
de télécoms castres comprends mais des
milliards ont déjà été investis ça a
pris du temps c'est des pertes quand
même importante pour les entreprises
waouh oui c'est plus de 5000 emplois
créés depuis 2008 ces 200 millions de
dollars en recettes fiscales ses 8
centres de recherche également au canada
tout ça reste en place il ya pas de
problème avec ça c'est pour ça que ce
soit on est très précis dans son
discours ce qu'on fait c'est qu'on
exclut les équipements les services de
huawei zte dans notre infrastructure du
5 juin parce que c'est ça on veut
protéger parce que c'est ça qui va être
critique non seulement maintenant à mais
pour les années futures parce que vous
savez quand on est dans ce jeu il ya
beaucoup il y aura beaucoup de
connexions c'est à dire que les objets
vont se connecter à l'internet les
voitures vont pouvoir se connecter alors
c'est important que tout ce réseau là
qui va être très présent dans nos vies
aujourd'hui mais surtout dans l'avenir
soit sécurisé c'est pour ça qu'on prend
une décision je les ai éclairer une
décision qui vient je pense au bon
moment parce que ça donne justement
comme le dit cette clarté la clé les
grandes compagnies de télécommunication
payer avait besoin à quelle sorte de
représailles et vous attendez vous de la
part de la chine pâques c'est une
décision dans l'intérêt du canada dans
la protection de notre sécurité
nationale la résilience de notre
infrastructure alors ce qu'on fait au
canada et c'est largement vous l'avez
mentionné je pense d'entrée de jeu en
ligne avec ce que nos alliés dans le
monde on fait alors vous savez moi ma ma
afzali au niveau des représailles ma
responsabilité moi c'est de protéger l
intérêt national protéger la sécurité
nationale et c'est ce qu'on fait avec
cette décision aujourd'hui peu importe
les représailles comme je vous dis comme
un élu responsable et comme gouvernement
c'est d'assurer la santé sécurité non
seulement des canadiens mais de
l'ensemble des réseaux critiques et
c'est pour ça qu'on prend cette décision
là aujourd'hui monsieur champagne merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce soir merci
d'avoir évité à bientôt pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit